there's like this i don't know it's kind
of like a celebrity
uh fantasy of i'm gonna buy my mom a
house
you know yes and i'm gonna uh you know
that's like the dream like
i'm gonna make it in the business and
then i'm gonna go up to my mom and i'm
gonna say mom
here are the keys right and it's this
and i know that you
wanted to do this for your mom that was
the dream but
you encountered some difficulties that
was the dream well
yeah i encountered some difficulties
that but that came later though the
dream
was okay i'm gonna give my mom a house
and then things didn't
happen as quickly as i wanted them to
and then my mom got tired of waiting she
was like you know baby you ain't gotta
buy me in the house you know just
keep funding my bingo habit i was like
[ __ ] i'd rather buy you a house
it's cheaper that way uh but so recently
uh with my my mother's newfound fame and
all of this
my mother can afford to um
go out and buy her own home on her own
now but she's still holding my feet to
the fire on this promise
that i made to her years ago as a child
that i would buy her a house whenever i
made it
so i got a realtor and we're looking at
places out by my mother where she lives
in south bay area bellflower where we
grew up
in l.a and compton and all that and then
she
then i recently purchased a new home and
i'm having it remodeled and she's like
what's she gonna do with this house
i was like i don't know she was like let
me move in it i was like i think about
it so me saying i'll think about it was
her saying
i'm moving in anthony's house he moving
out he gonna give it to me i was like no
mom that's not what i said
i want to live out by you okay marilla
just starts looking out for
for homes in the valley we find
five homes my mother goes to the first
one as i'm walking out of the house to
go meet her at the house
i'm not moving in this [ __ ] well mama
why
wait this street's too narrow she went
there ahead of you she went there ahead
of me got there ahead of me to to
scout the place out she's i was like mom
the realtor's there
why don't you just go in the house right
and look at it yeah nice moving into
this [ __ ] mama
the streets are too small i don't know
about this [ __ ]
mama just just going she wouldn't even
go inside she wouldn't go and i said
mama
you're there already you're she's
literally parked in front of the house i
said mom just walk in
i was like okay you don't have to get
this one just walk in it may
spark something for something that you
may like down the road now
meet me at the next one i was like all
right so
before i could even get directions to
the next one my mom is already at the
next one
and called me she said boy what is wrong
with you
why you got me looking at this race so i
i found a nice little compound because
my mother
my mother doesn't want to live alone she
wants her assistant to live with her she
wants my sister to come by right so i
found a nice
compound on an acre of land that had
three a main house and two satellite
homes on it
it needed a little tlc sure but i wanted
my mother to see
what you would get for the same amount
of money that you're going to pay down
down there someplace what should we get
in the valley come look at it and she
was like
why are you sending me here look at all
this dirt and trees and [ __ ]
what's wrong with trees trees are cute
i was like mama so she didn't even go
into that one there was a third one
and she drove up to that one and said
you know what this [ __ ] too far i'm not
moving out in the valley
and left so what do you do i never left
my house that morning
[Laughter]
she never let me leave the house to get
to the properties to look at
so i removed myself from the home search
and she found a home in uh carson
or torrance uh down the street from
drunk bobby her best friend
uh bobby she lives on the west side
of of the street and my mother lives on
the east side and it's about like an
eight minute walk to each other's homes
so um that's where she is and
uh she called me the other day and she's
like they're remodeling
uh i'm in escrow uh
i'mma call you or they gonna call you
let you know when you need to write the
check
i was like okay mama that's that's
that's what i'm gonna do she's moving in
april
april 13th but it's not a good i mean
obviously
the fantasy is mama you've always wanted
your own house yes i have and you toss
through the keys
yeah you've got one and it's and of
course it's not going to be that simple
no but i know on that day when she moves
in
and you write that check that's going to
be a great feeling no it is
it is it is i got to do that when i
first made some money i wanted to buy my
mom a car
i don't when i told her i was told when
i was a kid mom went someday i'm gonna
buy you a car
and i remember this is gonna be really
fun and i took my mother and she kind of
talks like she's very proper
right and she talks a little like this
and i took her to the dealership and i
said
do you like any of these cards and she
said i don't like the color black
no it wasn't was it it was like i don't
like black cars and i don't like blue
cars
i don't want black or blue and i'm like
you're ruining the moment
which which one do you want it can't be
black and it can't be blue i know
i'm just trying to have this be like a
fun well i just think
black it looks like you're going to a
funeral and blue it gets very dirty
i know you've told me that and so we
couldn't we couldn't get past that
so you didn't get her no no we did get
her a car but it was taking all the fun
out of it yeah
you know instead of like i can't believe
this is happening and hugging me right
right yeah that that's
that's how it is with my mom and because
of her bingo habit i just can't give her
cash i can't write her a check
you can't give her you really can't give
her an atm because that's gonna get out
of control yeah i can't
i can't give her the money i can't trust
her with the money to go buy whatever it
is
that i said i was gonna buy her so
that's why she's having
the the bank and the escrow people call
me and i just send it to them
yes but i got my mother a car once yeah
yeah never again
no right no never again
i'm gonna tell you a car story my mother
called me one day
uh she had uh a little suv
and she said maybe i want to get a new
car i was like okay i'll help you get a
new car then if that's the case
you know let's take that one let's go
trade it in see what we can get for it
and i'll get you something she said no
i'm gonna keep this one i was like okay
but
mom why are you going to keep it she's
like well
you know just in case my friends need
help moving
i was like mom you're 63
what friends of yours need help moving
at this age but i'm just going to keep
it i was like mom that does that doesn't
make sense for you to still keep this
car note
go out and have me buy you another car
just so you can keep this car around in
case your friends
need help moving i was like [ __ ] your
friends
i was like go to them and ask them to
help you buy a car then if that's what
you that's what you're holding out on
yeah so um i didn't get her a moving van
i didn't i didn't get her the second car
and so she went out and got it on her
own and still has
the suv to help her elderly friends move
in case they need to move